we're going to do the final stage we're
going to end up with the self compiling
compiler well in the previous video what
we did was we developed a C compiler by
writing it in assembler hypothetically
anyway and the net result of that is you
get a working C compiler that works on
the particular chipset that's in your
computer it could be arm it could be in
tell it could be whatever and it does
what you were expected to do it drinks
in C program statements and it spits out
at the other end so it's code generator
modules a binary which when suitably
packaged will become an executable on
your particular piece of machinery
traditionally under UNIX and Linux these
are called a dot out files traditionally
and the windows are called dot X's
aren't they but it's basically something
that is very very close to a loadable
venable binary as translation of your C
program and we left it last time if you
if you like you could say this is our C
compiler but we could almost call it the
mark 1 because we're saying
hypothetically we developed it via an
assembler root so when it executes it's
running assembler quality binary and
it's also producing shall we say
assembler quality binary I'll label that
compiler mark 1 so you say well what's
wrong with that why not just stick like
that we've got a compiler that works
well it could be a variety of reasons it
could be that's all though it's running
binary of quality a that binary could be
not very good it could be slow it could
be a perfectly good compiler but it
seems to take forever yeah that will be
one good reason for doing it there might
just possibly now you hope not be a very
very hidden bug that for certain C
imports it just crashes you hope that
testing and debugging have removed all
those but you can never be sure so
there's maybe another reason that
certain sorts of constructs
sometimes caused it to crash you don't
want that but what you're now saying is
can we use a not top-quality thing to
make a better instance of itself now
this is not a new idea some of the
commenters on my previous video have
been pointing out the machine tool
industry has been doing this for ages
using a not very good tool that's on its
last legs as a means of making something
that's sharper and better you can
imagine a 3d printer that has been
produced in a component-wise way by
other 3d printers and there is a vital
cog in the middle of it which turns
around a lot for some reason or another
and gets worn and what you'd like to do
is to improve the quality of that vital
cog near worried that it's gonna split
apart and do it so why not program your
machine to make that vital cog on the
machine as it now is and just hope it
withstands the stress until the piece is
made and then when the piece is made
it's got better tolerances and so on
hopefully then the is replacing so
you take the bad piece out throw it away
and put the new one in so you're
actually feeding back into the machine
itself a new instance of something that
is vital to its running so even out
there in the everyday world this
business of eating yourself or producing
a better version of yourself has been
around for a long time and we're gonna
do something very similar here what I'm
saying is ideally I'd like to make Binay
be history and a thing of the past
because I'd like to write a new version
of the compiler which we will call mark
2 so just to summarize this is a
compiler running binary code of quality
a at the moment and code generating
binary of a similar sort of quality we
now write a new version of the C
compiler still written in C which
produces better quality binary we pay a
lot of attention to the code generation
modules so we'll call it bin B
version 1 is a version to his be or you
can think of the B meaning better best
quality in some sense binary so that is
what you initially write you write a new
version of the C compiler which takes in
C it produces bin B you spent a lot of
time on that cogeneration modules and of
course at this stage you think of it as
being written in C which it is you're
writing a new C compiler in C but the
burning question then comes well I can't
execute C directly on the hardware I
don't have a C interpreter although in
principle I suppose you could develop
one know that C has got to be turned
into binary how do you turn that C this
is written in into binary when you are
in the process of constructing the new
thing and the answer is revert to the
previous generation revert to the one
that you've hoping to leave behind as a
means of propelling you forward as part
of the bootstrap process what we're now
saying is we do it like this we write C
producing bin B the new version of the
compiler written in C how do we compile
that C we have already got the old
Marquand version of the compiler which
you'll remember from the top of the
previous sheet takes in C runs on Benet
execute Binet let's hope he doesn't fall
over and squirts out binary of quality a
but that's sufficient to show C going in
there whirring round producing Binet
you've now got an executable which takes
in C produces much better binary of
quality B it's only weakness is that
it's still running itself on binary a
maybe it's still slow maybe binary a is
congenitally slow it's not being very
well written at all but at least it
works it's there some final step yes
there is that would get rid of any
vestigial remains of bin a in all
this process cycle yeah that is exactly
what you do next we've got a new version
of the C compiler but it's executable is
only still of been a quality how to
improve it feed the new version of the
compiler to the executable that you have
just created and it would go like this
look here's your new mark 2 version of
the C compiler C compiler written in C
producing bin B feed it through the
previous thing that we developed at the
end of the previous sheet what we ended
up with if you remember is a version of
the compiler now that can do C tube in B
so it's a new version the only little
weakness inside it is it's running bin a
but can you see that by feeding that
into a binary executable of itself what
you do is your feed you see in this is
running on Benet but it spits out bin B
so what you collect in your dot exe or
dot they doäôt file at the end is what
you want C producing bin B but running
on bin B so this is now our executable
for the new version but the beautiful
thing about it is that that remaining
weakness here where you use the old
version running Benet to produce a
version that doesn't have been a in this
at all final stage feed that back to
itself and that our sound of trumpets C
written and C producing bin B but as a
result of the previous exercise we've
now got a version of the compiler that
is the binary instantiation of this we
have got from over here a C producing
bin be written in bin B well use it use
it to recompile yourself and you end up
now with C written in bin B producing
bin B
any memories of the hell we went through
with the Assembly version can now be
forgotten you can throw that away and
carefully of course store away your
version now which only needs to get back
to AB in B level of history in order to
regenerate itself and I suppose you
could say therefore that this triumphant
theme which I put three stars on here
the product we were trying for all along
you can say it's now a self-sufficient
compiler as well as being a self
compiling compiler it's only needs a
working and debug version of itself in
order to be a wondrous new replacement
now things are never quite that perfect
there's always a downside I've got I've
got a question because he kind of sort
of alluded to it though it skips over it
nicely debugged right I mean what
happens if there are problems with this
you know where do we go you always have
to retain the ability to go back further
than you would wish of course you do it
yeah I think it is fair to say that
compiling a C compiler is a very heavy
and demanding task for a C compiler to
do you will get varieties of code usages
of data structures and all sorts in a
compiler that you will not likely find
in a weather forecasting program let
alone an events listing date calendar
whatever a compiler is a demanding thing
to write is going to be a demanding
thing to compile it may well be that
just saying oh here's the old compiler
that the old compiler just falls over
when faced with the unbelievable quality
of the C you've written for the mark to
the thing so yes that always happens you
can feed it to itself and then itself
falls over what what do you do well
you've got to back off and do it again
but you can see that in the end it is
the way to go get yourself use the whole
idea revealing something to yourself
- how shall we say motivate the quality
of the sea that you ride to be
compatible and giving a mind of course -
efficiency and so on all the way along
the chain but I do hope that this
example for those of you maybe been a
bit puzzle saying what is all this
bootstrapping one of the problems I
think is that even sometimes when you
see T diagram explanations they make it
hard by not distinguishing if you like
between bene and bin B I've seen
explanations which just right bin and
don't make it clear that it's a
different sort of binary you know and
and that I think causes a lot of
confusion so I hope this has helped is
it possible that this goes through
doodles more that's the technical term
doodles more iterations he got Ben C
bindi Binney oh yeah yes yes if you
decide that well bin B was fine for its
time but frankly there's a witty new
idea with interlocked Triple R F
pointers pointing to data structures
that do this on the other and that's
absolutely the way to write that next
version of the C compiler then you can
do exactly the same thing you be daft
not to use the previous version of the
compiler to compile yourself but what
you must be careful of is that if you're
in the process of as it were defining
the subset of the language of the C
compiler compiles your hope it will be
total but there may be glitches in it
you've got to try and write C that it's
capable of compiling itself and you've
got that in your mind all the time when
you're doing this worst case scenario
yes exactly yes yes I'm a fabulous
compiler but please don't feed me with
myself all hell may break loose yeah
yeah
and the cube mouse click events we
probably wouldn't get one whether the
mouse is move if you think about as the
mouse is being moved you've got lots and
lots of events most of which you're not
interested in you're probably only
interested when a button is pressed or
so on the only times pass that's
different is it cause for your dragging
something around the screen